you're willing to say let's go ahead and
it raised interest rates again jun even
if inflation is still a forecast it has
moved higher that's right as long as the
inflation they are consistent with the
forecast I have of moving towards 2%
that would be enough now you know as you
mentioned we've been missing
undershooting inflation for quite some
time but you know in terms of the you
and I take that seriously in terms of
thinking about what's happening but in
terms of monetary policy let's remember
interest rates are still very low I'm
not talking about having one interest
rate increase you know in the next few
months or whenever isn't making tight
monetary policy it's just stepping back
a little bit from the very accommodative
monetary policy so it's not about
tightening policy so much it's just
pulling back a little bit on the
accommodation we've had in place of
courses you know market expectations are
once again a little bit out of sync with
the Fed because right now basically you
could say the markets are pricing in
just one interest rate increase you've
had people like Larry Fink from
blackrock and Jeff going good luck from
a double double line talking about just
one interest rate increase this year if
that so you said even two or three
basically not two but even three rate
increases are reasonable this year what
is it that you see the markets don't
what are the markets missing well first
of all the markets aren't one person
there are you know millions of people
involved in investing and making you
know forecasts and decisions around that
so there are different views when I look
at the markets the data from the markets
what you see is a kind of a bimodal
distribution a lot of people think that
the modal or the baseline case is the
one that I played out of the
unemployment continuing to come down
good job growth two percent gdp and
inflation moving back you see this in
the survey of professional forecasters
the blue-chip surveys you see it from my
own colleagues in our own dot plots in
our own SCP forecast there is this other
part of the distribution which I under
you know I think of is related to
concerns about Asia concerns about
Europe and Japan the rest of the world
that there's this downside scenario
where global growth really slows other
things happen and that that's a negative
shock to the US so obviously that's
priced into the market the possibility
of a negative scenario that seems to get
a lot of weight and investors minds so
my view that the we should be gradually
raising interest rates
here is based on the notion that we
follow this baseline scenario that the
data continued to come in show the US
economy continues to be on the good
track and under those conditions we
should raise rates clearly if the
downside you know risk really do happen
that we see really negative effects in
the US economy then we should pause and
wait until it's appropriate to raise
rates oh I see the markets of trying to
kind of balance these two different
scenarios and come to their best
estimates and what we should do but you
know again I'm my answer to your
question really is the my baseline
scenario where which is preop domestic
so there was stay on track depending on
track then the June rate hike is a
likelihood in your view and certainly
something you would support at the very
least well so I don't want any
likelihood because you know we're never
supposed to talk about what's going to
happen if Holmes he means we're my
colleagues are going to say and of
course we're gonna get a lot of data
between now and then and we'll have good
discussions but in my view yes it would
be appropriate given all the things we
talked about to go on that that next
step but you know a lot can happen
between now in the middle of June